To in contrast, switches perform some amount
of traffic isolation so that the entire
LAN doesn't become one broadcast medium. But
instead, we can partition the LAN into separate
broadcast domains or collision domains. Now a
switch might break the subnet into multiple LAN
segments. Typically a frame that is bound for a host in the same part or
segment of the LAN is not forwarded to
other segments. So, for example if we had a
network with three hubs, all connected by a
switch, then each of these would be its own
broadcast domain. And if a host here wanted
to send a frame to another destination in the
same segment, well that frame would be broadcast within
that domain. But the switch would recognize that the
destination was in the same segment. And would not for the packet
on output ports, destined for other LAN segments where the destination was not.
Now enforcing this kind of isolation,
requires constructing some kind of switch table,
or state at the switch, which maps destination MAC addresses to output ports.